[Música]
hace aproximadamente unos seis años y
comenzar me cuenta de que un perro puede
tener muchísima más humanidad que el
propio ser humano de hecho si no fuera
por el mío y su inevitable necesidad de
saludar a toda persona que nos
encontramos por la calle les aseguro que
jamás habría sabido de la existencia de
mi vecino francisco
francisco es vecino de abajo les
saludamos casi todos los días excepto
aquellos en los que llueve esos días
francisco desaparece y es el rincón de
la acera donde siempre solemos
encontrarlos se queda hueco se queda
vacío se queda sin su inquilino
nuestra sociedad se encuentra sumida en
una desigualdad tan sumamente
inabarcable que con el paso del tiempo
nos hemos hecho inmunes a ella cada día
cerca de 370.000 personas nacen
alrededor del mundo
cada una de estas vidas ya está escrita
ya viene con fecha de caducidad y esa
fecha no es igual para todos si
analizamos la naturaleza política de
años pasados podemos evidenciar como
ciertas personas han estado destinadas a
tener un tiempo potencial de vida menor
que otras personas que vieron su
existencia comprometida debido a su
lugar de origen debido a su raza a su
sexo a su orientación sexual a su
religión mientras que en españa la
esperanza de vida es de 83 años en
nigeria es de 54 y mientras que cada
mañana todos nosotros aparecemos en
nuestra casa entre 25.000 y 30.000
personas siguen sin hogar en nuestro
país
pero cuál es nuestro papel en toda esta
situación qué parte del cambio está en
nuestra mano bien la clave está en
comenzar a dar visibilidad a estas
situaciones a estas personas no podemos
permitir que haya un sector de la
sociedad que sea invisible
necesitamos una técnica que nos permite
identificar de manera rápida y eficaz
cuando una persona está sufriendo una
discriminación ya que desarrollando
empatía podemos percatarnos de la
necesidad de actuar es por ello que
diseñé esta fórmula donde la desigualdad
nace del desequilibrio entre el tiempo
que debemos emplear en buscar unas
necesidades básicas de supervivencia y
el tiempo que podemos disfrutar a
nuestra libre elección
te has planteado que de las 24 horas que
tiene cualquier día no necesitas emplear
apenas una en buscar alimento abrigo o
un lugar donde dormir porque ya tienes
todas estas cosas
crees que la rutina de una persona como
francisco que carece de prácticamente
todo lo necesario para sobrevivir podría
asemejarse en algún momento a la tuya
si todos los seres humanos tuviéramos
garantizado unos derechos humanos
básicos un sector de la población no
tendría que emplear la mayor parte de su
tiempo en sobrevivir la desigualdad se
reduciría con creces y la libertad se
aproximaría cada vez más a ser una
condición que todos podamos alcanzar
acepta tu papel porque ya lo dijo noam
chomsky si asumes que no existe
esperanza entonces garantiza que no
habrá esperanza si por el contrario
asumes que existe un instinto hacia la
libertad entonces habrá oportunidad de
cambiar la cosa
[Aplausos]
[Música]